[Musique]
ici yannick dumont baron bienvenue à
madrid sur la place à majorque on
devrait peut-être appeler la place amène
or ces jours ci regardez ça ce sont les
effets du confinement
c'est une place qui est d'ordinaire
bondés on peut entendre les gens parler
ya presque personne aux tables des
restaurants c'est vide me disait un
serveur tout à l'heure ça ce sont bien
sûr les effets du confinement et les
effets aussi de la peur d'attraper le
corps un navire us en venant à madrid
[Musique]
il
là il est passé 22 heures à madrid place
à santa anna normalement ici devrait y
avoir beaucoup de gens parce que
évidemment les espagnols mange tard le
soir
mais là les restaurants ne peut plus
accueillir de nouveaux clients après 22h
pris tout le monde doit dégager à 23
heures ce qui fait que cette place qui
normalement devrait être plein de gens
elle est en train de fermer mais pense
assez madrid qu'on finisse et madrid
avec ses restrictions de ports aux
navires us et une majorité qui est
triste selon les gens qui habitent ici
[Musique]